[Music]
now i get tons of people that don't like
dave ramsey because there is a segment
of people in our culture
that don't like to be told
that they can win
if i tell someone that is hell-bent on
being a victim
that they can win
they don't like it
it makes them mad
don't tell me i can win because then i
that takes away all my excuses
it takes away the fact that i might have
to deal with the person in my mirror
and uh if i convince you that your
category whatever category you have
stuck yourself in
i'm skinny i'm fat i'm man i'm woman i'm
black i'm white i'm purple i'm pink i'm
latino
i don't know what i am i'm from the
north i'm from the south
i have this or that
i don't know what your thing is but i
can tell you after 30 years of doing
this i've met one just like you who made
it
and if you want to live in the soup of
your self-pity and in the soup of your
victimhood
you're going to not like dave ramsey
so personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
and once you get that dialed in then
you're in a place to go okay yes there's
outside variables
yes sometimes there's mean people in the
world yes sometimes there's racists
sometimes they're sexists sometimes
there's a whatever ist that's there's
jerks and foolish and ignorant people
everywhere
they're all around us
and yet it's still your job to control
what you can control and they're not one
of the things you can control
you can control the person in your
mirror
and then you
become successful
tada
is it easy well crap no if it was easy
we would not recommend successful people
so
last summer
uh i guess it was last summer we had at
our entre leadership event
one of the sharks from the shark tank
and
he and some of his folks and some other
friends of mine all got together at my
house for a big dinner afterwards we
ended up sitting on my deck and talking
until the wee hours of the morning and
became
that night lifelong friends i'll just
tell you i just love this guy and i
heard he was doing a new project an
audible project and i got him on the
phone because i want you guys to know
about it so uh america's shark you gotta
love him damon john is with us hey my
friend how are you
what's up brother i uh i love what you
were saying as i just tuned in and um
and yes it was a very it was an amazing
experience being with you and your
family and everybody so really good to
hear from you man well it's good to hear
from you i'm excited about this project
so you're gonna tell people
how you built a six billion dollar brand
called fubu
uh i mean we get to see on the shark but
that's small potatoes compared to fubu
and you did this man started i mean 40
bucks you are a rags to riches story and
you overcame some crap without a doubt
to do that i mean you you got
misunderstood abused and betrayed and
everything else and still pulled it off
and uh which normally happens to all of
us but sometimes people think that line
of success doesn't include that much
manure but it did in your case it did in
my case for sure that's one of the
reasons we became fast friends but talk
about this new audible original about
founding fubu what are you talking about
in this
yeah yeah so the waterloo original is so
there's there is no book to this that
has now become an audible this is purely
an audible original greatly produced it
is talking about my found my days that i
founded what i went through all the
things and all the all the things that
happened to me good bad or ugly a lot of
behind the scenes story such as you know
you start having money coming around
there's bad people and good people to
come around i didn't think though that
for your listeners that they can learn
from is the community that was built you
know the same way you know we're seeing
too many communities that are fighting
because they're apart we're not getting
enough of the good stories of people
like who listen to your show they
couldn't care less about other people's
color gender and race and all that other
stuff it's about communities you build
and and really how we ended up growing
and how i made a ton of financial
mistakes a ton meaning closing fubu
three times from 89 to 92 running out of
the first hundred thousand dollars that
i had and almost being homeless and then
blowing around 20 million dollars when i
first made money and i think that's
important for people to learn too
because you know fiscal education and
responsibility is something that you
learn every day you keep growing there's
no way to just arrive at it and i think
that a lot of your listeners can
absolutely take away from those big
mistakes that i made and thank god i'm
still here
after making those mistakes
what was the best
financial decisions the best three
decisions
best three habits or disciplines
around money that you develop that you
attribute to being able to stay on top
of it
i think uh living within my means
and understanding that i think
understanding credit
um
and i also think um probably in general
understanding how money works from a
taxes perspective
uh
from interest
and understanding how to allocate it
accordingly and i think all three of
those really uh kind of kind of stay in
tune and align with each other um but
you're gonna say three i think that it's
going to be the fourth one is also the
investment you know being able to not
only have to go out and work for my
money but letting my money work for me
and not you know not taking as many
chances as you know i took in the past
because i had money i made my my most
my most ignorant um
or my most uneducated decisions was when
i had the most money that's when i made
the biggest mistakes
well you get you kind of get fat and
sloppy we all do right
yeah it's kind of like yeah that little
bit don't matter that little bit doesn't
matter i got it i got it all of a sudden
you're like holy crap i don't got it
you know how many of the sharks how many
of the shark deals are paying you money
right now are you still making a profit
on
um i would i would think that around
three out of ten i make a profit on um
uh probably two out of you know because
two out of ten are kind of the
they're kind of trying to figure out who
they want to be when they grow up and
then the other five out of 10 they just
didn't work out they uh
um you know i don't want to talk bad
about the entrepreneur maybe having
their time but you know they made bad
decisions or
uh you know they didn't educate
themselves enough it's a three-hour
audible project called founding fubu you
can listen to it at daymondjohn.com is
that right damon
absolutely all right be sure and check
it out guys this guy's awesome thank you
damon